foreign
cancer awareness month comes to a close
it's the last day we bring you a
reminder that it is never never the
wrong time to get screened let's say
that again never the wrong time to get
screamed screen ladies this year breast
cancer is expecting to kill more than 43
000 women in this country but early
detection is helping more women survive
the disease CBS News contributor and the
editor at large at kfs Kaiser health
news Dr Celine gounder documented her
annual exam in mammography 101 she hopes
to demystify the process and explain
again why regular screening is vital for
detecting breast cancer early
one of the awesome things about being a
45 year old woman is it's three times
the fun with cancer screening you've got
screening for breast cancer colon cancer
and cervical cancer my name is Danielle
I'm going to do your exam today I'm
going to place your breast here on the
plate just some slight compression just
enough to keep your breasts from moving
we will do this in several different
angles taking a breath hold your breath
you can put the Gown back on on the
right side and we'll do the side view
and taking a breath and hold your breath
beautiful okay
great looks good
I'm Dr Donaldson hi my name is the right
and the left and we get an image and two
views for each breast so that we really
can look at the full volume of the
tissue so these are your breasts your
mammogram more zoomed in and enlarged
and we very carefully look at really
every inch every area of the breast
looking for anything that really doesn't
belong there
and so far you look fantastic
so Celine gowner joins us here at the
table let's just get right into it you
know do you have that moment that I do
when you're sitting there waiting it's
it's the waiting for them to walk in the
room and I'm trying to read their
expression before they say either yay or
nay did you have that moment yourself as
a doctor when you're waiting to get the
news
we're glad no abnormalities were found
by the way very glad but did you do you
have that moment too or no not really I
didn't I didn't I had done a self breast
exam before going uh to the appointment
and was pretty sure I was you know low
risk and wasn't too worried I don't have
a family history but you know you never
know many women do not have a family
history something like 85 percent of
women do not have a family history when
they're diagnosed with breast cancer but
there's still so many women despite all
the statistics that say I'm not going to
get it because they're afraid of the
process or I've heard somebody say I
just don't even want to know which is
not good thinking in my opinion yeah
look a mammogram does not give you
breast cancer it's really important to
know a lot of times people will say to
me oh that test gave me such and such
disease and no it helps you find out
that you have it it helps you get care
more quickly if you have it and it's
really not a painful process it's sort
of awkward and you have your breasts
compressed between two plates but it's
not painful and it's uncomfortable I
think it depends on the technician and I
swear if men had to have their peonies
matched with way we do with our breasts
they find another way to do it but right
now but that's this is all that we have
it can be a little uncomfortable
depending on who's giving you giving it
to you but there's that is not enough
not to go and get it right it's not it's
not painful it doesn't pinch it's just
sort of awkward yeah so when should
women get a mammogram
on the organization
um their recommendations do vary um
some organizations will say every
years
across the board definitely you want to
start at age 50 and then if you have
risk factors so for example a family
history obesity if you drink heavily if
you smoke those are risk factors then
you may want to start earlier as early
as age 40. and some women get a sonogram
in addition to a mammogram what's the
difference
sonograms are used to tease out to have
a letter a better look at abnormalities
they might see on the mammogram it's
more likely that you need that in
somebody who has dense breasts younger
women do tend to have denser breasts and
there's sort of a difference in
philosophy here some doctors will say
let's go ahead and get the the mammogram
and ultrasound in the same visit so you
don't have to come back that's what my
doctor does others will say well does it
really make a difference you know does
it really save lives maybe we should
wait and see if we really need that I
want to get every test possible and
that's exactly what I do it's troubling
to me though that black women are 41
percent more likely to be diagnosed with
breast cancer than white women why is
that so therefore you die from breast
cancer yeah they're more likely to die
from breast cancer than white women and
there's this is because there are
disparities at every step of the process
so they're less likely to get their
mammogram on time they're less likely to
get the newer 3D mammograms than a 2d
mammogram so a 2d mammogram you're
basically looking at all the cross
sections of the breast flattened into
one image so 3D allows you to have a
better look then once they're diagnosed
they start treatment later and they're
less likely to get standard of care you
know the recommended treatment is it
because they don't pursue it or the
doctors don't encourage it there's a
difference some of both that's some of
both yeah then there's certainly
barriers to getting the mammogram Dr
sling grounded thank you so much Vital
Information life saving information and
you're okay we'll be right back that's
all clear that's the best news of all